ça sert à ça a c'est marie ça c'est
stéphane de tout ça c'est pierrick et ça
c'est vraiment toi vous vous demandez
probablement comment on en est arrivé là
nous aussi
[Musique]
il ya quelques temps le musée national
des 100 naturel m'a mise au défi tester
vigie terre leur programme de science
participative autour des cailloux tu
parles que ça m'intéressait donc j'ai
réuni ma game de géologues amateurs et
nous sommes allés faire un petit tour en
région chez nos amis perpignanais qui
sentent bon le soleil et les rousses qui
à la découverte du massif du canigou
dans les périls et orientale on regarde
valentine oui qu'est ce qu'on fout là et
bien jeanine tu peux ficoba
qu'est ce qu'on fout loi est bien
jacqueline nous sommes ici pour faire de
l'urbex mais à la campagne c'est un peu
dur rex et le but c'est de trouver des
affleurements de cailloux qu'ils soient
un peu curieux ou alors insolites ou
grandioses et du coup valentine sait
quoi en affleurement c'est une roche du
sous sol qui ressort en surface est
comme ça on la voit c'est pas de la
vieille callas tout naze comme ça ça
c'est du quaternaire on s'en fiche
blague de géologues du coup on cherche
des appelants et attention à ne pas
confondre avec un effleurement
voyez-vous des affleurements autour de
nous
sommes et oui comme cela allons voir
[Applaudissements]
là tu vas sur le site de visiteurs tu
peux rentrer ton signalement taille de
l'affleurement est ce qui fait plus à
partir de 10 mètres ou de 1 à 10 mètres
8 8 25 mai à l'état pur
voilà ça c'est bien anthropique ou
naturels ah bah là on est sur un site
naturel on n'est pas en ville nature du
site on a quoi aux affleurements des
travaux sont-ils en cours non quelle est
la nature des roches du site tu peux
dire si la roche et magmatique
sédimentaires métamorphisées tu le sais
grâce à ma vidéo qui s'appelle je
referme une géode avoir sur la chaîne
youtube sur le comptoir cissé
sédimentaires on peut voir des strates
ou des couches en général tu peux
trouver des petits cailloux des
coquillages défaut si c'est volcanique
on peut avoir des petits trous dedans de
la porosité et cissé métamorphiques
c'est le bordel métamorphiques c'est des
trucs qui sont complètement repris des
deux précédents en fait tu prends
n'importe quelle première ruche et tu en
fais une
et là franchement c'est métamorphiques
rouge transformée sous l'action de la
pression et de la température
elle peut présenter une structure en
feuillets des fois ce qui peut aider
c'est de mouiller la surface du caillou
fait pour mieux voir ce qu'il ya dessus
et
donc ça c'est une roche métamorphique un
mika schiste donc c'est un schiste avec
des feuilles acquis riche en mikari et
le mika
c'est un minéral qui en fait y'a aussi
est qui et qui brille c'est
métamorphiques donc c'est métamorphiques
mais si jamais tu sais pas et battez pas
obligé de le renseigner tu peux juste
dire oh là on a vu des cailloux rigolo
et puis après il ya des vrais géologue
qui rend sur le terrain donc après il
nous faut des photos du site mais pas
n'importe quelle photo il nous faut une
échelle parce que sinon comment tu sais
c'est un truc tout petit ou très grand
on peut prendre une pièce de monnaie
c'est un petit machin où on peut prendre
n'importe quoi des clés une gourde un
sac à dos ou une personne si on
[Musique]
il faut prendre tout l'affleurement pas
juste stéphane
une fois notre signalement envoyés sur
le site de vigie terre il parvient à des
géologues relais du programme qui vont
l'étudier et nous faire des retours de
son histoire de faire avancer la science
sur cette vidéo on a eu la chance d'être
accompagné par un vrai géologue en chair
et en os pour nous en dire plus sur
cette affleurements du plus bel effet et
voici ce qu'il nous a dit
mais c'est pas tout car il nous a aussi
dit ceci vous êtes devant le plus
vieille roche des pyrénées voici donc
comment ce mic assiste ses formes et
nous sommes il ya 600 millions d'années
au fond de l'eau nous levant les yeux au
ciel quand une délicate neige marine
nous chatouille joyeusement le museau
cette neige c'est du sable et des
cadavres de bestioles de toutes tailles
du plancton aux poissons et aux
passagers du titanic ces sédiments vont
s'accumuler au fond de la mer et donner
des roches sédimentaires il faut un bon
dans le temps maintenant nous sommes 300
millions d'années avant bernard menez ce
cimetière marin est pris en sandwich
dans la formation d'une nouvelle chaîne
de montagnes et ce faisant ce fait cuire
et recuire talent une bonne
bouillabaisse cette chaîne qui sort de
terre c'est la chaîne hercynienne vers
signe un set une époque très lointaine
où l'ancien continent de gondwana s'est
rapproché de continents situés plus au
nord et ce à écraser tous qui avez entre
les deux et ça a donné la chaîne
hercynienne que l'on peut suivre du
marocain asie centrale et qu'on retrouve
sur l'autre rive de l'atlantique et
pendant cette grande compression
sahraouis c'est le terme scientifique
des fluides chauds avec de la vapeur
d'eau dedans en profitent pour se
balader à l'intérieur de ces pauvres
pauvres pauvres roche c'est ce qu'on
appelle des remontées hydrothermales
sauf que l'eau n'est pas tout seul à
squatter la rochelle transporte avec
elle des éléments chimiques qui vont
précipiter à l'intérieur du caillou et
c'est ainsi qu'entre en scène la star du
coin le faire ce qui explique pourquoi
ici les cailloux prennent des
colorations grouille par endroits où
arbore de beaux cristaux ça c'est de
l'hématite je pense elle est associée du
quartz il ya des quartz filoniens ça
c'est des choses c'est des choses
hydrothermales hainaut l'hématite c'est
pas une une maladie c'est un minéral
riches en fer
et ce sont ces minerais qui ont été
exploitées
depuis l'antiquité
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle dans le
secteur où nous sommes et oui la
géologie ce n'est pas uniquement étudier
des cailloux fait aussi mieux comprendre
grâce à eux l'histoire de la région
l'histoire géologique certes mais aussi
l'histoire des humains qui vivent et
pour ce faire jeux de mots s'est entouré
des avengers du canigou et notamment de
monsieur bo qui connaît le coin comme sa
poche vu qu'il en est maire et qui va
nous présenter ce véritable cabinet de
curiosités bien que ce soit un élu par
contre on n'a pas tenté le concours
d'anecdotes cette fois faudra battre les
prochaines données sur le site minier
des menottes sur la commune de labastide
un massif du canigou s'était mis à ciel
ouvert cette exploitation n'a pas duré
très longtemps entre les deux guerres et
plus précisément sur le site tournée
jusqu'en 1927 c'était des mineurs
paysans c'est à dire qu'ils
travaillaient l'âme il ya même temps il
travaille la terre malheureusement parmi
ces jeunes là il n'y a plus aucun témoin
ici mon grand père à 14 ans était
forgeron d'en bas à la mine donc il
faisait sa tournée il faisait 10 heures
et en redescendant il s'arrêtait
travailler le champ de maïs ou de pomme
de terre suivant la saison et le travail
qu'il s'était déjà qui faisait 13 et 14
heures par jour sur la pénibilité du
travail fait qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de
témoignages je pense que mon grand père
n'a jamais voulu pâtit grant et moyens
c'est très compliqué et tout ce qu'on
sait on a dû la prendre en bout par
l'homme en faisant quelques expériences
initiale de rechercher un petit peu donc
on est arrivé à découvrir des choses et
d'ailleurs il ya des documents qui
n'explique pas tout à fait la réalité du
fonctionnement de cette partie de la
mine donc ce que les hommes n'ont pas
forcément réussi à nous raconter c'est
dans le paysage qu'on va le lire et on
peut remonter loin comme ça si la
dernière exploitation de cette mine à
ciel ouvert remonte à 1927 la première
pour le court montré carrément à
l'antiquité les romains exploiter de
faire l'amour au people exploité à même
le sol il faisait pas de galerie très
très peu et quelques vestiges de la roue
et amis noirs pour la paix la voie
romaine qui défendent ligne toute la
montagne qui passent en phase sur le
mamelon qu'ils en fassent les couilles
et bon allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc là on est devant une entrée du
valeureux en fait c'est une à une
fouille à l'exploitation n'a pas été
terminé le principe c'était aller
profond s'il ya du minerai on a exploité
c'est ce qui s'est passé ici ils ont
commencé ici par le bas en faisant un
tyran des cartouches de dynamite qui
partait en montant c'est pour ça que
vous avez cette falaise et qui
n'existait pas avant la montagne a été
telle qu'elle est de l'autre côté voilà
ce qui reste une carrière à ciel ouvert
dans le ciel des courageux on va aller
jusqu'au fond donc allez suivez mon
salaire trop bien
[Musique]
et donc c'est comme ça qu on extrayait
le minerai de fer en faisant sauter les
pans entiers de montagne tout en
délicatesse
dans quoi les cailloux contiennent en
moyenne 50% de faire c'est énorme et ça
peut même grimper à 97% par endroits
vous voulez voir des voix la
[Musique]
broquerie
renouveau bienne
bon là ils viennent de trouver un point
noir sur un caillou il faut seulement
que c'est quelque chose d'intéressant je
vais essayer de me fondre dans le groupe
en faisant aussi sanglant que ça
m'intéresse
une fact le grenat s'appelle comme ça
parce qu'il ressemble aux petits grains
dans la grenade on a exploité le grenier
du château
il ya longtemps que les grenat catalan
me chantait avec de la pierre locale
ben oui parce que c'est pas tes serment
des pierres qui ont la qualité
pour l'étayer
c'est là qu'on voit là
on va au muret en pierre et on voit que
c'est un
caraco là j'avais un plan incliné les
wagons qui monte t il descendre et avec
le minerai de fer
[Musique]
c'est la go acheminer le minerai
jusqu'au fourre tout où tout en bas où
il était grillé pour en extraire une
partie du fer mais on y reviendra à ses
thèmes ou des mineurs et oui ça fais
là je vais vous êtes bilingue les plus
gros et puis j'ai voilà il est plus
léger tout simplement parce que ça c'est
une scorie ça ça a été fondue ils ont
transformé sa croissance sur le faire et
voilà ce qu'il en reste est facile à
tout un tas de cette occasion ses débuts
du minerai consultoria été extrait
[Musique]
une oasis minérale eu beau milieu de la
forêt ça fait un siècle que ce tas de
cailloux attend d'être descendu pour y
être fondu mais il peut toujours
attendre puisque la mine est morte vive
la mine qu'est ce que tu as trouvé
valentine un morceau de minerai typique
regarde et on voit bien les cristaux
dematic là
dans une gangue un peu rouille et e on
voit encore mais
alors à quoi reconnaît-on une hématite
et ben c'est très simple comme ce sont
des polymorphe al fahd oxydes de fer
s'efface tabulaire présente une
structure rombaut hydriques en pentaèdre
inversée associé à appeler au cros isme
bear et fringant alors que les grenats
ce sont des silicates à cation dit
valant regrouper un site tetra hydrique
de coordination 4 au cas où il y aurait
encore besoin de le préciser
[Musique]
et c'est pas fini parce que il faut bien
l'alimenter ce four bon avec du charbon
ça d'accord mais il faut aussi
entretenir la flamme et pour attiser
cette flamme il nous faut de l'eau de
l'eau
on avait des températures de missane de
graines leur balançant c'était un
courant d'air provoqué par des vidéos
qui attiser le feu d'imagés à cuba avec
un y ont fait courir le dessus dessous
les automates qui commandait la fox a
trois neurones
[Musique]
l'antienne tu peux pas censé être avec
des amis géologue équipé d'un bouton
ans
voilà géologie c'est comme ça que je
lève
rien de neuf mais tout est pareil du
coup j'avais aimé ces cailloux vous avez
aimé cette balade et bien tant mieux ce
qui est bien c'est de protéger la nature
et donc si vous aimez la nature ne
ramassez pas des cailloux sur le bord de
la route et tout parce que ça fait de
l'érosion vous voulez pas érodé vos
paysages donc c'est pour ça que les
cailloux on les regarde avec les yeux
nous repartira avec absolument rien dans
nos poches parce qu on est juste venu là
pour pour s'inscrire et voir la beauté
des lieux
valentine
on y va
et voilà comment l'ingéniosité humaine
assure extraire le faire des entrailles
de la terre c'est bon on dirait du
malade mental et surtout c'est quand
même un énorme progrès pour l'humanité
parce que avant de savoir faire ça on
extrayait le fer contenu dans les
météorites d'ailleurs je vous invite à
aller voir la vidéo que j'ai fait pour
le vortex sur ce sujet et surtout voilà
la fenêtre d'histoire que nous a ouvert
notre affleurements du début et oui on
peut lire tout ça dans les cailloux il
suffit de savoir où et quoi regarder
mais je laisse le mot de la fin à arnaud
qui va nous résumer la géologie de la
région avec ses propres concepts
ça non
ça va
j'espère que cette vidéo un peu spécial
le chef du kkl que vous aura plu je suis
ravi d'avoir pu vous emmener sur le
terrain parce que c'est la première fois
et c'est quand même une part importante
du métier de géologues et vu que j'avais
pas eu l'occasion de le faire avant bas
merci merci à vigy terre pour cette
super occasion et ce qui est absolument
sensas c'est vous pouvez vous aussi
contribué à écrire l'histoire géologique
de votre région en observant des
cailloux je sais pas pourquoi je crie
alors gardez les yeux ouverts autour de
vous il lorsque vous croisez des
affleurements béal et les signaler sur
le site de visiteurs ça prend vraiment 3
et 23 secondes sur venus parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
tout n'est pas cartographie même en
france j'aime juste vous sortez de chez
eux et ben non et donc au gré des
éboulements des glissements de terrain
ou des travaux de btp on peut voir
apparaître des nouveaux affleurements
qui risque de disparaître aussi vite
qu'ils sont apparus sous nos yeux d'où
l'utilité de renseigner tout ça pour que
des scientifiques puissent aller
explorer les parages et améliorer notre
connaissance du sous sol du coup de
l'histoire géologique au culturel de
votre région si vous voulez un tuto plus
détaillée de comment qu'on fait sur le
site de visiteurs je vous invite à aller
voir la vidéo de géo lynx dont je mets
lien en description vous avez maintenant
toutes les clés pour participer alors
enfourchez votre boussole chausser votre
carte ign et est coiffée votre saucisson
on part à l'aventuré
on y va là
d'ailleurs j'y vais
[Musique]
est ce que vous auriez haye
ouïe très fine à bout de cette aventure
excitant
oh
il y en avait sur la de l'effondrement
moi je suis venu là pour les
affleurements des journées
plagioclase bear est rageant
[Musique]
oui qu'elle fait ça doit d'être un
auteur à succès
[Musique]
structure rambo hydrique
j'ai reçu un mail de file
je peux pas commenter plus que ça faites
vos recherches
non mais
non je ne sais pas mais c'est juste
cette question n'était pas très
pertinentes comme une chance
[Musique]
non
[Rires]
[Musique]